on the streets of Aldershot a rehearsal
to ensure military Precision come
coronation day
it will be a chance to play a part in
history taking their place in an 8 000
strong procession escorting King Charles
and queen Camilla from Buckingham Palace
to Westminster Abbey and Back Again
and with one week to go details of the
service itself have been revealed the
coronation service has elements of
tradition in it that date back to the
10th century and before and it's really
beautiful and profound in that respect
but also it is very much rooted in the
present and in the reality of modern
Britain the diversity of Britain the
fact that the Church of England has
women Bishops the fact that we're a
multi-faced society and the fact that
we're also a society of people with no
beliefs the climax of the ceremony has
arrived
years have passed
on May the 6th
steeped in centuries of tradition
[Music]
tonight a service was held to Mark the
arrival of the Stone of Destiny from
Edinburgh an ancient symbol of
Scotland's monarchy it was the item used
at the inauguration of Scotland's Kings
right up until the end of the 13th
century
and it was removed by King Edward the
first in his hope to try and stop that
process happening and it stayed in this
chair that he built in Westminster Abbey
and it was used at every coronation
right up to Elizabeth II and then about
25 years ago it was returned to Scotland
and it lives in Edinburgh Castle every
tiny detail has been considered down to
the smallest Stitch of the robes to be
worn by the king and queen four in all
they include one seen here on the
shoulders of Charles's grandfather
George VI at the coronation of 1937.
there's also a new nature themed robe
created for Camilla
many here have only just returned from
overseas but preparations for the parade
have been underway for seven months it
is a complex operation but we've been
able to really you know go into the
detail leave no stone unturned and and
issue some really comprehensive orders
the corner Nation will be watched by the
world every element orchestrated and
executed to ensure not a single step is
out of place
Emma birchley Sky News